i know you love a christmas miracle
because you're as holly jolly as i am
and here is one that i think you'll love
from australia
the new york post reports that a woman
returned home
to find a very awesome and aussie
surprise in her christmas tree
oh my goodness now that is a little
koala bear
just in the christmas tree surprise uh
it's a fake tree but the kuala bear
didn't know it when you snuck into the
house
uh and the koala bear it's fine rescuers
took it and
took care of it you know what i also
loved i think one of my very favorite
stories of 2020 which is perfect for
this christmasy spirit episode is
rockefeller which is the owl that they
found
in the rockefeller center big famous
christmas tree
yeah so they brought in this kind of
like shabby tree that didn't look so hot
i thought but in it was rockefeller this
little tiny owl
i think that he's a perfect metaphor for
this year he came inside of a tree that
was not ideal
but there he was there was beauty there
there was beauty and a gentle little
spirit
and i am just like i don't there was
something about that story that just
like
really resonated with me i do i just i
give a hoot
and yeah you know you found it i think
you're i knew you would
owl i will love you i do and you
you just you stole my heart you really
did
you you talon lies drew i am
and what i'd like to see is now a cage
match between rockefeller and that koala
per view girl right okay and finally cnn
business reports
that santa zuman is a boomin okay
so ross there's this entire virtual
industry
that has kicked off and i have to say i
like this better
than the santa behind plexiglas i always
look forward every year to going to the
mall to meet
them as a kid and i actually thought
like what did kids do in 2020
well they got it figured out guess what
ross what
we've got a zoom in coming from the
north pole
right now are you kidding me standing
[Applause]
merry christmas i wanted to surprise you
merry christmas oh it's good to see you
guys
and a big hello to mrs claus how are you
today so much true
the brains behind the twosome is right
we're so happy to see you we're
so happy to see you too and ross you
know is a big santa fan yes i am
big fan ross you have
really grown from last year oh my
we're goodness proud of you you're such
a big
good boy all year long santa all year
oh my gosh yes that's hard for you to do
but you've been
good all right you do know
mr and mrs claus that i have
i've worked very hard on myself this
year and normally i feel like i'm top in
the naughty list as
nice as i am to everybody i know i'm on
that naughty list for something
or several things and this year i have
really
really really worked hard on myself and
i've tried to look at all my flaws
and go to work on them well it's really
great that you clean your room
and you answer to the adults whenever
they want you to help
and we're really proud of you very proud
of you
thank you very much i love zooming them
i love it
thank you mr and mrs claus it's such an
honor and a pleasure to have you here
you're making things okay for people
and that is above and beyond what you
already do for everyone we get to
look into the eyes of children and
full of joy and their shape in their
eyes
it's the greatest thing any touch of
normalcy
is the best a merry merry christmas to
you bo merry merry christmas happy
holidays
thank
merry
you
[Music]